the endless beaches of France and the
majestic mountains of Austria in any
normal summer German tourists love to
head for these and many other European
beauty spots but because of the
coronavirus the route to Germany's
neighbours has been blocked at the
borders for many the pandemic has given
travel and new importance of course it's
about our health all around the world
but they can't take away our freedom to
travel not because of Corona or an
economic crisis I'd like to go to Spain
I don't know if that's possible it
depends if the Spanish opened their
border at the moment there's no sign
maybe we'll know in four weeks
blocking proposal but there is a sign
from the German government how it plans
to reopen its frontiers the border with
Belgium and the Netherlands was never
closed from today police will not patrol
the Luxembourg border either to the
north Denmark has said it is willing in
principle to allow the traffic to flow
but needs more time to work out the
details Germany's borders with France
Austria and Switzerland have been seeing
a loosening of restrictions that means
that here at the Austrian German border
anyone with family or property on the
other side may now cross over and if
there's no major news spread of the
virus the Czechs will be completely
lifted in mid-june the borders with
Poland and the Czech Republic have not
been closed by Germany but rather by the
governments in Warsaw and Prague Berlin
is hoping to persuade them to open their
frontiers that the uncertainty has made
some Germans rethink their plans I think
I'll just work a lot this summer and
then go away in the autumn I hope I
won't take a holiday this year it makes
no sense there's still a long way to go
until Europe's vacation hot spots are
crowded but now Germans at least have a
timetable for when they will enjoy the
freedom of movement once again
correspondent Bastian Hartig is on the
German Austrian border in the town of
Kieffer's Feldon from where he joins me
now Bastian
it's good to see you again and it's
clearly a big day where you are
the border between Germany and Austria
reopened just a few hours ago give us a
sense of what the situation is yeah as
you can see Michel it's fairly quiet
there's one car at the checkpoint right
now but if you look over here this Lane
Ivan I've been told is up until
yesterday this was packed with cars at
any given moment because police pulled
over every car that wanted to cross the
border now they're only checking at
random if you do get pulled over like
that car behind me they'll ask you why
you want to enter the country then you
have to make their case to the officers
and if they think your reason is good
enough they'll let you through if they
don't they'll turn you back and they'll
escort you back across the border to
Austria Michel
so it's random checking along that
border what are some of the restrictions
that will remain in place for certain
okay so those restrictions have been
eased just a little bit since yesterday
so before that basically only people who
were commuting for work for example or
German citizens returning home they got
to cross the border now that definition
has been expanded that now includes
people who want to visit family members
on the other side of the border for
example or people who want to have real
estate on the other side that they need
to attend to they now get to cross as
well what's still not possible is
crossing for touristic purposes or for
shopping trips for example Michael I see
so it's still early and you likely
haven't had a chance to talk to many
travelers but what's the collective
significance for people who have an
intention of crossing from one side to
the other
welllook okay so first of all there's
these people who live close to the
border they routinely cross before the
corona crisis they they would cross the
border just as a normal routine in their
daily lives now at the moment they can't
do that or only very restricted but on a
bigger scale holiday season is coming up
so people want to know if they can go on
a summer holiday Austria is one of the
favorite destinations for German
citizens they want to go to the
mountains they won't enjoy their summer
holiday there at the moment they don't
know if they can do that now the border
controls or the borders should be opened
by June 15th but that is that depends
highly on the number of infections so
the German interior minister said if
those infections surged on either side
of the border then that there the plan
that they have opening the borders by
June 15th can't go ahead and even the
easing of the restrictions that has
taken place yesterday ortant last night
will be what will be walked back Michael
our correspondent Bastian Hartig with
the latest from the German Austrian
border much appreciated Bastian now on
the other side of that border Austria is
also moving forward with the easing of
coronavirus restrictions on Friday the
country took an important symbolic step
by reopening its restaurants and
traditional Viennese cafes but strict
safety guidelines will have to be
observed it's the new normal in the age
of covert 19 a toast to a new beginning
after more than seven weeks restaurants
and cafes in Austria have been allowed
to reopen but only if they follow strict
guidelines staff must cover their nose
and mouth and tables have to be at least
one metre apart with no more than four
adults sitting together for many it's a
welcome step it's not quite the same
normal state as before but I think it's
good for everyone to get together again
I hope the laws are going to be a little
more relaxed so that more people can
come together zoos have also opened
as the government moves to lift
restrictions across the country after
bringing the number of new infections
under control and keeping deaths
relatively low art exhibitions and
museums are also unlocking their doors
its admissions agri-food ever said I
missed it very much it helped that you
could visit the museum's online but of
course that's not the same as in real
life larger cultural events such as
concerts are being allowed to restart
gradually between now and August as long
as organizers devise safety measures
that meets the government's approval for
now though it's a return to a semblance
of normality but Austria's approach is
being closely watched by other countries
also looking for ways of opening up the
economy while preventing a second deadly
wave of the virus